>> LEPAGE: All right. Good morning everybody.
Thanks for joining us. You know, I think back
to the first website that I started building
back probably 15 years ago or so, and it was
really about content, giving, putting content
on the Web. It wasn't about interactive video
at all. All of the graphics that I had, the
most interactive graphic I had and the richest
graphic I had was the little shovel guy, the
animated gif that was doing that kind of thing.
And as the Web has matured, we've seen a lot
more interactivity come. We've seen a lot
more richer graphics, right? But a lot of
those things sometimes required a little bit
of black magic to happen or we've had to do
server side processing of all of our code
in order to get those really rich graphics,
really rich experiences, and really rich websites
and web applications. But HTML5 really gives
us the platform that we need to be able to
build web apps that feel like they're native,
that feel like they've got the power, the
same experiences and really have those awesome
webs--web apps that we expect. So we're talking
today about getting started with HTML5. My
name is Pete LePage. I'm a developer advocate
at Google. And I'll let Ernest introduce himself.
>> DELGADO: Yes. Thanks Pete. My name is Ernest
Delgado and I'm also in the Chrome Developer
Relations Team focused mainly on HTML5. Pete?
>> LEPAGE: Awesome. Thanks. You can follow
us on Twitter and we'll be having--spending
a bit of time on Twitter today. As we're going
through, please if you haven't already, have
a look at the SpeakerMeter website and provide
feedback as we're going. And don't forget
the BootCamp I/O and the Chrome Twitter hashtags
as we're going through these things. The plan
for today is we're going to talk about what
is HTML5. We're going to dive into what we
can do with it and how we can start using
it today. This is really sort of a 100-level
talk, but for those of you who have played
with HTML5 before, don't worry. There will
be a few good nuggets in here. There's going
to be some really neat stuff. The other thing
that I want to mention is that we really can't
go through all of the new features of HTML5
in a single one hour session. We'd probably
be here for the next four hours and we'd get
maybe half the stuff, so we just sort of picked
a bunch of our favorites that we thought were
the most interesting. All right. If you want
to see more, we'll have some resources at
the end that you can go and check out. As
well, these slides and the code that we're
showing today is going to be available to
you after. So don't worry about scribbling
down any notes or like any--anything, code,
snippets or anything like that. So the first
thing I want to start with is what is HTML5
and what does it mean? At Google, we think
about HTML5 as the collection of web technologies
that have really come to maturity in the last
two to four years. So that includes things
that give us a really rich development platform
as developers that we can go and use really
rich APIs to provide offline access or offline
storage, so that I can store data on the user's
computer without having to send it back and
forth with cookies. Or that I can get access
to things like device hardware. Getting access
to maybe GEO location for the user or how
their laptop is sitting, whether it's tilted,
whether it's straight up and down, all of
that kind of information. But it also gives
us access to things that we can make our applications
run faster as well. And so, we're going to
dive into those. And it gives us access to
things that make--allows to build more beautiful
web apps. No longer are we limited to the
sort of, "Oh look, it's a white page with
like a couple of words on it and it's not
all that pretty." We can do some really rich
graphically intense stuff that we could never
do before with video and audio and canvass
and CSS styling. So the way we sort of decided,
we wanted to show you this is by building
a web app that takes tweets from the Chrome
Dev Rel Team and visualizes them in this kind
of neat way. It drops them down. So it's pulling
all these tweets from Twitter and it's using
CSS3 Animations to drop them, so all these
guys here getting drawn and using CSS3 Animations,
the older the tweet is the more transparent
it becomes, so you notice on some of these
tweets you can kind of see, on those ones
you can see through it, this one you can't
see through it at all. So we are using opacity
to set the age of the tweets. We're using
Geolocation to be able to provide information
about where people are. If I have a look here,
this tweet here that's a little bit lighter
on screen as I make it--mouse over it gets
bigger, it's saying there's geolocation there,
and in fact, we provided additional rendering
of geolocation on these tweets. We also have
notifications. I'm not going to turn these
on right now because I want--we'll show--have
a look at these a little later. But we also
have an ability to be able to search. This
is I think one of the coolest things. So speech
input. So I can click this little guy here,
free cake. Sure enough, there's all the tweets
that include the words free cake. All right,
the amount of code that I had to write to
do that, not much. All right. Under the covers,
we're using IndexDB to store all the tweets,
so that even if you weren't online you'd still
be able to see all of these tweets. And we're
using Web Workers to go and get the tweets
and put them into the database. So with that,
I'm going to pass it over to Ernest who's
going to talk about the stuff that we did
for the Rich User Experience.
>> DELGADO: Thank you Pete. So I'm going to
show you some of these APIs that we've used
for this app. And starting for speech input,
which is the last one he demoed, and this
is the shortest snippet that you're going
to see today because actually, to enable this
feature, we only added this attribute to the
input field that we already know. So the good
thing is the browser is giving us a lot of
UI for free that we don't need to do with
JavaScript. For instance here we have this
input field inside this bubble, and when we
click on the microphone does this part that
you seen that is going to tell us, "Okay,
it's time to talk." I'm going to try to say
free cake with a much worst pronunciation
of course. Free cake. Okay. At least it recognized
it. So we have these words here, but now we
want to do something else. We also have an
API that we can access from JavaScript and
do more stuff. For instance, here if we attached
like an event to the input field and say when
it changes, just trigger this function. The
event object returns these lists of results,
and we can go through the list of results
to do different stuff. I'm going to do the
same test here with the free cake. Free cake.
And I didn't say it very well. So it was the
second guess actually. The system understood
that they said create and the confidence for
that was 0.2, so the confidence wasn't very
high. But I'll try to pronounce it better,
let's see. Free cake. So now it gets free
cake and with a confidence of 0.8, so still,
we have a list of all the other guesses, like
free games, free skate and so on. But the
confidence wasn't very high for that--this
confidence as well as the string which is
called the utterance, these are data that
we are getting from this API. And when we
are saying a word this word is sent to the
cloud, as it happens with our phone, the voice--the
voice recognition. We don't need to do any
local voice training to get accurate results.
It used to happen that with a local, like
desktop software for this matter, but now
that we're using the cloud we don't need that
anymore, and that's really cool. So another
feature we were using the--in the app is Geolocation.
And this is really useful to build your apps
with customized content based on the location
of the user. And just--we are just checking
for navigature--navigator.geolocation to check
if the browser is supporting this. And then
using the watch position method, which is
actually running in the background to check
for the position constantly, and then in the
position parameter we get like the coordinates
latitude, longitude, and one that is not showing
here on the screen but is the accuracy or
something like that, that actually if I'd
run this demo we're going to see. It says
that access denied because we need to enable
geolocation. We can do it here, I think that
we could have done that from this app as well
because it needs to be like user enabled by
side books which show location here, yes.
I see. So help me here a bit. I need to claim
the results for that.
>> LEPAGE: What we did earlier, we did a rehearsal
to make sure everything was working, and we're
like, "Oh let's just deny access for now,
so that way we can have it work properly when
we actually go do the demo."
>> DELGADO: Yes. I'm going to create here
now.
>> LEPAGE: Yes. Helps to clear to that after
you deny it.
>> DELGADO: Perfect. Now it should work. So,
let's refresh. So these you could see the
level of protection that the user has. So,
when we ask here for geolocation it--it's
both asking us in the bother bar. We allow--allowing
now this feature. And it's saying is that
we are at this position. Not very good actually,
because it says actually that the accuracy
parameter that I told you before it's saying
that it's 22,000. So in the background he's
using like IP-Lookup or any information that
the browser has, like a Wi-Fi connection,
like a spot--AP spots, so that's why it asked
the user for permission for these kind of
things. So as in all demos that you try it
live it works, but try it at home and it will
be better. And the way we're using it here
in the TweeterFall application is that he
mentioned before that the tweets that have
geolocation attached in that geo object that
you get when you use the Tweeter API. We are
highlighting them here in this list. So we're
using this position of the tweet compared
with our position in local. And if that person
is very far that we chose in this fall down
here, like smaller or bigger, but only for
those with geolocation, in this case, it would
be like this tweet of Mike West. So, how many
people here haven't heard about Canvas yet?
So--okay, not many. And it's not surprising
because this is one of the features that has
been around for a long time in HTML5 and it's
funny to see how we've evolved over time.
Because it started with all these methods
to make basic shapes and draw lines. And it
has also other methods for transformations.
And as you can see here in this drawing, it's
related but the edges are, like, kind of cut
off. And this is because we're not rotating
that whole canvas element, only the content
inside. And, obviously, the size it was like
wider and not as much as high. And that's
just understand that we're doing the modifications
at pixel level. Also when we rotate this image,
there's no transition we have to do, like,
a four loop and do the animation by hand.
That's why after this thing was kind of popular.
There were many frameworks that where on top
of that to kind of easy of these programming.
Also, there's like a processing syntax wrapper
for that. So there are many libraries on top
of Canvas. But the power of this is really
high. And also we can use images or videos
to import it in the canvas, get the frames
and modify the pixels. And here--just as a
proof of concept, we have these two images
here and just--they have been imported inside
the canvas just to place them, not a big deal.
But then we can export that with the--to data
URL, to Internet, to any PNG or JPEG back
to the image tag if you--if we want. So we
will go back to the TweeterFall app.
Another proof of concept that we put here
was that right now the background is this
CSS pattern and if we enabled like animated
background is doing this fancy stuff that
taking, like, some star's image putting it
on--putting it on top with some opacity. Also
doing this color changing and this animation
and it was really complex to do that only
with JavaScript or images so pre-running that
with Canvas is much easier. So if you could
remind this rotation I did with Canvas, if
we want to rotate the whole element. Now we
are able to do it with 2D transformations.
So, it needs actually--just from CSS, we just
set some properties to transform and rotate
like 90 degrees but the cool thing is that
if we combine that with transition then we
have the whole animation between the two states
and we didn't need to do like in Canvas like
every frame redraw the whole thing. So in
the tradition we're all saying--just saying
800 milliseconds and that's what it's going
to last but now it means that we are able
to do it on any element. So I hovered this
code, it's going to do it as well, just because
I pre-run it like that but I could do it on
the title or on the whole page if I wanted
to. So this transformation is the one--are
the ones that we use in the Tweeter application
to make this thing bigger. And, actually,
the code, I think I have the snippet here.
These are the two stages I was talking about.
I'm saying like, an initial state where there's
no rotation at all and a final state that
happens when I hover that tweet using the
CSS selection. And then we have like the scale
that's why this--the tweet is getting bigger.
And some translations just to make it like
go not outside of the boundaries and what
happens here is that you see many lines because
in CSS, when something new comes, they are
like the browser prefixes that allows us to
use that new feature in the browser. And later
when it becomes standardized, then we don't--we
won't need that anymore. But, at least, when
browsers implement things with different syntax
or little differences, we are able to do--use
that right away in the browser using these
prefixes. There are also 3D transformations.
These are really cool feature and also one
of the latest. And here, when we say rotation,
we can specify on one--what axis we're on
in that rotation. And everyone--like a 90
degrees going to flip whatever we have on
the screen and it's going to give like the
impression of the 3D because we added this
prospective parameter. So we didn't do anything
here with 3D in this app but if you pay attention
to these slides, the way that they are doing
the transition, they are doing this kind of
3D effect that where we're using the 3D Transforms.
So this not meant to be like a whole 3D environment
or a game. You have, like, the Web GL context
in the canvas tag. We're going to not talk
about it because it's really a dense subject.
But you have a specific talk on I_O tomorrow
if you're more interested or if you are a
game developer. And now, let's make our site
prettier because actually, for many, many
years, we had those eight fonts in our browser
and we were limited to those eight fonts.
And since you shouldn't be using Comic Sans
for your site, we are limited to seven--eight
font types. So the cool thing to them or the
Web fonts, that now with this feature, we
have access to thousands of fonts. Is this--to
use this extension made by Pamela Fox, and
this point actually a list from an API that
we have at Google is the Google Fonts API
and we have all these fonts that we can preview
and when we selected anything on the page,
like the code there is changing and we can
say, "Okay. How it looks here on my site?"
And if we like this font for our site, then
we can copy-paste this code and put it in
the header and boom, yes, we have the fonts
available already. The only thing is that
if you want to host the fonts because, with
this API, Google is hosting the font file
for you. So if you want to get the true type
and host it in your own server just put it
in the folder and then use the syntax in CSS.
You say font family with a keyword that you're
going to use in your spreadsheet and then
source with a link to wherever you put your
font type--font file. And, actually, here,
I think, you have seen already that this font
is actually text is not any much replacement
or any crazy [INDISTINCT] that web developers
used to do and is using this font for here.
I think the font for the text is also another
one so it makes--actually, designers are really
happy with this feature now. And the last
feature I'm going to show you in this section
is Web Notifications. An easier way to understand
this feature is if you are using chat or any
chat or email software in your desktop but
I wouldn't be surprised that all of you maybe
are using web-based software for that already.
But, obviously, if you are using still, like
the desktop, you'll be familiar with the notifications
you have on the top right on Macintosh and
on the top bottom windows. And we'll be, like,
kind of the scanned--similar to that but what
we're seeing here actually are screenshots
of the web notifications because, actually,
we want this kind of feature for our web apps.
I'm going to show the demo first here because
as it happens with geolocation, you need the
specific permission from the user and then
we have to say that, okay, we're allowed to
do that. That's because we are the one the
user to get, like, spam or any popup from
any random site, he needs to know where he's
giving permissions for--to receive these notifications.
So if we receive--let me see, for instance
here, kind of--there are these notification
here that it's showing more than the UI and
this notification at desktop level. Now it's
disappearing. So this notification that we
get here and probably we're going to get some
more--if some of my teammates tweet now, we're
going to get those tweets from now until the
end of the talk. And it doesn't matter if
I focus on that app or you have the browser
modified, see, this thing is showing right
here now, from my boss actually. And I hope
she's not watching me. The snippet for that
is that we have this function. And when we
call this function, we check if this site
has permissions from the user to show notifications.
And we're using this single method to pass
through parameters like a picture, a title
and the content. And, actually, since we're
doing it from Tweeter we have all the--that
information from the json object of the--of
the tweets. There's another kind of notification
that we're not showing here that is called,
I think, create HTML5 note--HTML notification.
So instead of three parameters, we parsed
one single parameter with HTML content and
that's going to show up in the notification.
We're using a similar method to show and this
is why the notification was hiding after a
while. Because, by default, that thing--the
thing is going to stay there until the user
goes and closes it. But maybe we think that
that's annoying for him because there are
too many notifications up to the developer.
So we set--we set this set timeout and he's
going to close after a while. And, actually,
if you use Gmail or Google Calendar or even
TweetDeck or some other similar app, you can
enable this feature because they are already
supporting that. With that, I'm going to pass
it over to Pete to talk about some more features.
>> LEPAGE: Awesome. Yes. Thank you, sir. All
right. So Ernest went through some of the
sort front-end and user experience stuff that
really allows us to make our applications
feel like they run on the desktop. I'm going
to take a look at some of the things that
allow us to build applications that are more
powerful, that give us more APIs than we've
ever had access to before. And really allow
us to do stuff that we couldn't do or if we
did, we had to like, as I mentioned earlier,
use some of that black magic, use some JavaScript
that wasn't really meant to do something and
innovate something through this and that and
just not really pretty ways of doing things.
As we started building this app, one of the
things we realized we needed to do was stored
data. And we could've done that using cookies
but we wanted to store the configuration data
for this application on the user's computer.
We use Web Storage to do that. Web Storage
allows you to store name value pairs of data,
so it's--you know, you've got the name and
then value is only a string. So we're using
that to store this configuration information.
There's two type of Web Storage that are available
to us. There's sessionStorage which, like
it sounds like, its lifetime is for the session,
so you close that window and you've lost access
to it. And then there's localStorage. And
that last for until the user blows away their
cache and clears out their browser. The way
we're using this in our app is we've got another
function called getSettings. And getSettings
says var settings equals localStorage and
it goes and tries to get the string from localStorage.
It then tries to parse that string into a
JavaScript object. Because it's in there as
a string, we want to get it into an object,
so we can handle it a little bit more accurate--easily.
And so, settings, JSON.parse. Now I've wrapped
that and try cache block because what I want
to do is say, hey, if you fail or if there's
any kind of problems with this thing, we'll
just go create a new set of settings and then
we're going to pass those back. Then to store
that data into the configuration, we just
do localStorage, square bracket equals and
you give it the key, and then you give it
the string that you want to put in. Again,
because we're taking a JavaScript object,
we need to turn it into a string because we
can't just shove a JavaScript object into
there. We're using JSON.stringify, and that
allows us to get our configuration data into
the app. So all of the information that's
stored around which Tweeter username and which
user list we want to store, as well as, you
know, how many tweets we want to show at any
given time. Whether we want to, you know,
if I turn the notifications off and reload
the app; sure enough the notifications are
off. So every time we start the app, we started
in the same set of configuration that we used
last time.
We also wanted to store additional stuff on
the user's computer that localStorage didn't
really work for. We wanted to store all the
tweets that the user had seen on their computer.
And so, indexedDB is a new set of, a new database
object that comes as part of HTML5 and it
allows you to store significant quantities
of structured data, all right? Now, there's
a couple of things that we're going to have
a lookup but before we dig into this one at
all, I just want to stop and sort of grab
everybody's attention for one sec. A lot of
the new APIs that you get access to is--with
HTML5 are asynchronous. Put your hand up if
you've done like an AJAX request and you know
how you deal with, sort of the asynchronous,
yes. So you know how with that kind of thing,
you have to give it a callback because the
data might not be there when you go ask for
it and it's going to go and do stuff asynchronously.
Well, many of the APIs that we get as part
of HTML5 are that same way, all right? And
indexedDB is definitely one of those and you'll
see in a sec how we--how we went about dealing
with that. So, to initialize a database with
indexedDB, I've created a function called
initDatabase and I give it a callback for
dbReady and that callback is called when my
database object is ready. So there's a couple
of things we need to do to initialize a database.
First thing we need to do is set our version.
So I've set var dbVersion, the answer is 42,
you can use a number, you can use a string,
you can use whatever you want in there as
long as it's a legal JavaScript something,
you can set it in there, all right. And then
we say, request indexedDB open. And that opens
the database that says, "Hey, indexedDB go
open yourself up for me." And here's where
we have our first line where we need to deal
with an async call, right? Because we don't
know when that database is going to be ready,
we can't just count on it being ready as soon
as we call open. So we say, request onsuccess
and I've created a function here. And I've
said database, now I have to declare this
is a global variable because I want to use
it in a bunch of places, e.target.result,
and that gives me access to the database.
Then I want to check to see if the database
version that I've opened is the same one that
I'm expecting. If it is, great, I'm just going
to call database ready and we're good to go,
and we can start using it. If it's not, then
we've probably made some changes to our database.
Maybe it's a new instance if our application
is running, or maybe we've create a new table
or we've change some of the object types that
are in there. So, if it is a new version,
we need to set the version to the new ones.
We've got database set version and we set
it. And then, again, the same thing, we need
to do an asynchronous call in and say, Ver.onsuccess
and I go in, I create the tables. So where
you see here the object store name contains,
so we check to see if it's already there.
If it's not, we go and we say, create the
store and we set the key path to the index
that we want to use. And you can use whatever
you want in your index here. And then we go
and say, hey, we're ready, you can start using
us. To get data from the database, same general
concepts apply. So, in this particular instance,
all right. And this is the actual code from
the app. If you actually go and look at our
app and go view source, you're going to see
this function with this exact code in there.
So we've set an item callback and we've set
a completed callback. The item callback gets
called on each item. So, like we go, and in
fact use it to stick stuff into an array,
and then we callback completed callback when
we've done all of our looping through. Now,
you're going to notice these three lines,
these three lines are pretty much the basics
of any indexedDB request. First thing we need
to do is do var trans database.transaction,
all right? So we need to go to get a transaction
access into the database and in this case,
because we're reading, we're going to do a
read-only request, all right? So we're just
saying, hey, read-only. Then we need to go
say store, trans.objectStore, we want to get
access to that table, right. We want to say,
"Hey, give me all of the items in that particular
table." And then to get the individual items
from there, store open cursor. Now, indexedDB
works via cursors, all right. So instead of
like a SQL notation were you say, select star
from table tweets, right. This gives you a
cursor and it allows you to iterate through.
It's almost like a four each kind of statement,
so you run through. In our onsuccess, once
we have our first cursor item, we say, we
go get our cursor. We check to see if our
cursor's undefined because we're done when
we've hit the undefined and we did the callback
if we're done, and if we're not, we do the
item callback. So we say, "Hey, I want you
to take--I want to take you and I want to
just shove you into my array or do whatever
you want." In our particular case, we're doing
a couple of things. We go and, as we pull
the stuff back, we go and add it to this list
on the right and we add it to the items in
the--in the database. To add stuff to a database,
similar concept. Those three lines are almost
exactly the same, right? We need to go get
our transaction, access to the database, this
time we're going to change that first line,
instead of doing a read-only we need to do
a read-write because we want to put stuff
into the database. We need to then get the
store, get that table and say, "Hey, we want
access to the table." And then we can actually
start putting stuff into the database with
store.add, all right. Store.add adds a new
row effectively; it's the way to think about
it. There's also store.put which allows you
to replace an element. So if you've got, you
know, two elements and you want to put one
in and replace one with the other, you can
use store.put. Now, I haven't put anything
in my onsuccess or onfailure callback other
than a console.log in this particular case.
But in something like this, more than likely,
you'd probably just want to put some error
handling in your onfailure and in your onsuccess
you might want to deal with something that
is, okay, we've already got the thing in there
or what have you. All right. Helps if I open
the lid. How many of you guys have seen this
dialog popup or a similar dialog when you're
surfing around on the Web, yes. Yes. That
dialog kind of sucks, doesn't it? You know,
one of the things with JavaScript is that,
JavaScript runs in the same thread as our
UI, right? So that means if you try and do
any complex JavaScript calculations and--or
maybe you get yourself into a race condition
or you're just doing something or somebody
else is doing something more than likely,
because we'd never write code that did this,
we're all--right? Yes. All right. Because
you're running in that same thread and you
lock up, well, it feels like the browser locks
up and the browser pops that dialog up and
says, "Hey, I'm sorry, this guy is taking
too long. Do you want to kill it or do you
want to wait for it?" So, there's a new set
of functionality in HTML5 called Web Workers.
And Web Workers allows you to say, hey, I
want to take this chunk of JavaScript and
I want to run it in a separate thread from
my browser UI code. I want it to be completely
separate, I don't want it to interfere, just
go off and do your own thing. Just come back
and tell me when you're done. So that's what
Web Workers is, and if this really cool way
to be able to go and run stuff off in another
place. Now, I've got some sample code here
and I'll show you how we're using this in
the app, but I wanted to sort of walk through
the sample code to give a specific example
of where were the--where you'd do some real
complex calculations. So, the calculated Fibonacci
Sequence if you remember those, that you add
the two previous numbers. Well, those get
really computationally expensive as your numbers
start to get larger and larger, right? So
you trying and run that with a number of a
hundred and your browser is just going to
go plunk and stop working and it's not going
to be pretty, right? So, I created a Fibonacci
calculator using a Web Worker. So the first
thing we do if we say var worker equals new
worker and we give it a link to the JavaScript
that we want it to go run, right? So it's
a separate JavaScript file, lives off in its
own little world. And then because it's running
off in its own little world, the only way
we can talk to it or it can talk to us is
through post messages. All right? So we need
to listen for any messages that it's going
to send us. So we had add an event listener,
that listens for messages and we're just going
to popup a dialogue. And then finally we need
to send it a message, we need to tell it to
go do something. All right? So worker post
message and we send it 12. Then in our actual
Fibonacci JS, so this is the actual code that's
running in our worker, right? We need to listen
for messages, right? Because, well, we're
sending it stuff so it needs something to
listen. So, self.onmessage and we go and we
start using our Fibonacci sequence. So, we
go and do that calculation. When we finish,
we do a post message to send back to our parent
to say, "Hey, I'm done. Here's my value."
All right? Now, the reason we need to do it
this way is because it's running off in its
own little world, all right? It doesn't have
any other access to most of the things we're
used to. It doesn't have access to the window
object. It doesn't have access to the DOM.
It doesn't have access to a lot of stuff,
so the only way we can get messages back and
forth is with the post message. So sure enough
this guy runs and we get a result back with
our Fibonacci sequence. Now, how are we using
this in our application? In our index.html,
we have a function called startWorker, all
right? And that goes and it says, same thing
we saw before, var worker equals new worker
and it points to the script that we want to
start running in its own little thread. We
had add our event listener that says, "Hey,
any time you get a message I want you to send
that message and handle it with newTweetHandler,
so that newTweetHandler is going to go and
handle any of the content that we send it
from our worker." And then we tell our worker,
"All right, time to get started. You're good
to go." Within the worker, again, same concept,
self.addEventListener. We listen for new messages
and we start the function that's going to
go on read the tweets. So this is the--in
our worker thread, this is what's actually
going up to Twitter and say, "Hey, Twitter,
got any new messages for me? All right. Nope.
Okay, fine, thanks. Got any new messages?
Oh, you do. Great, thanks." So it then takes
that message and it sends it over to our application.
Now, you'll notice I used the line here, importScripts;
importScripts. Remember I said earlier we
don't have access to the window object? We
don't have access to the DOM? Means we can't
go into adjacent P request. We can't create
script elements in our DOM so we can't have
any of that stuff going. So we need a way
that we can be able to insert script into
our application. And so there's a method called
importScripts and it works synchronously,
right? So this one is not a sync. This is
synchronously. So it goes up to Twitter and
I've just shortened the URL here just so that
it would fit on the slide. But it goes up
to Twitter. It requests the tweets. That then
inserts the JavaScript that Twitter sends
back into our worker and then that code gets
executed. All right? So, that's how web workers
work. They go through. They grab our information,
off in their own little world and they send
messages back and forth. All right. I want
to go to sort of some basic stuff for a sec
because I think this is one of my--it's the
easiest part of HTML5 I think but it's also
one of my favorite parts of HTML5. HTML5 makes
our markup and our seman--our markup much
more semantic and much easier. How many of
you guys have the HTML 4.01 DOCTYPE memorized?
Right. You know, usually when I asked that
there's like two people who put up their hand
and there's probably two people who have a
memory that good. I could tell you I don't,
right? Like, I know it's DOCTYPE and that's
about as far as I stop. All right? I'm used
to the tools inserting it for me. HTML5 gives
us a new DOCTYPE that's a heck a lot easier.
DOCTYPE HTML, much easier than that big, long,
crazy thing. And this will stick all of the
browsers into their most compliant rendering
mode giving us all of the HTML5 features.
One of the other things that becomes easier
is we've got this meta charset equals utf-8.
We don't have to go and put in all those big,
long complex name and value and content and
all that kind of stuff. We've simplified and
made our markup a lot easier. There's also
a bunch of new semantic elements and they
went through when they were going and deciding
which semantic elements to add by looking
at all of the markup that you guys have all
written over time. And they looked at what
classes and what ID's appeared most often.
Sure enough, things like header, footer, article,
nav were the most common classes and ID's.
So why not actually give those their own elements.
They also changed the meaning of a couple
elements. So elements that had a stylistic
meaning in the past, they changed those to
have a semantic meaning now. I think my favorite
one of those is small. It's still going to
render in the same way, it's still going to
be small text, okay? But what's going to happen
is instead of it rendering--instead of it
just having the visual meaning, it now has
a semantic meaning and that semantic meaning
is the small print or the fine print that's
on the bottom of a legal document or maybe
the fine print that's on the bottom of your
webpage. So, it gives it a semantic meaning.
There's also a bunch of elements that, well,
they haven't been deprecated, they've been
obsoleted if that's a real word, okay? And
they're still going to work. They're still
going to render exactly like they did before
if you're using them in your markup today,
they're still going to work. But the only
thing that's really going to happen is your
friends are going to look at your code and
your friends will laugh at you. That's about
it, right? And honestly, do we need a reason
to get rid of the marky tag? Like, come on.
Really? The bling tag? Things like center.
You can do that with CSS style. So that's
why those elements are gone now. In our application,
the way we actually use this is we created
the application really only using three main
sections. Across the top we've got our header
element, all right? And that's just an element
that runs across top marks our header. On
the left, we've got a section that contains
all of our falling tweets and on the right
we've got an aside and that aside is the tweets
on the right. All right. Form elements. Bunch
of new stuff to make form work easier, right,
so that if you've got input types, there's
a bunch of new ones like--excuse me, email,
phone number, dates, times, and things to
make validations significantly easier. One
of the cool things about these new elements,
think about like on a phone if you are going
to enter in a phone number, isn't it nice
when the device actually shows just the keypad?
So by doing that, you can not only provide
functionality for the device but you can also
add placeholders and patterns. So let's take
a look at at our application for a sec. I'm
going to pop this open. There's a couple of
things that are going on. I'm going to take
this text code here. Notice that there are
a couple of things happen. This guy turned
to some light gray text. I'm not sure if you
can read it in the back but it says username.
That's a placeholder, right? If we wanted
to do a placeholder in the past, we had to
do that with JavaScript and it was kind of
a pain in the butt because sometimes the JavaScript
wouldn't fire at the right time and--or the
user would start typing before the placeholder
got popped in and then all of a sudden, oh,
not only does the user have what they type
but they also have a place--well it just got
to be this big mess, right? And unless you
had like awesomeness coding skills, not exactly
the most fun. So I'm going to put this back
in here. There's also this range element that
allows us to specify a range. There's all
sorts of new ones, the code that we've got,
all right? So, there's what we've got for
the placeholder. I say placeholder equals
username and so that placeholder just automatically
appears. We've also got a required attribute.
I want to point this one out specifically
because this is something called the binary
attribute. And the first time I ever used
it, it goofed to me up pretty significantly
because binary attribute is true if it's there.
It doesn't matter what you set the value to.
If it's there, the value is true. All right?
If you want to go and set a value on it, you
can. You can say required equals required.
You could say required equals true. You could
say required equals, hi mom. All right? All
of those are going to evaluate to true. What
happens if you say required equals false?
It's true. So, keep that one in mind because
I kid you not, I probably spent half an hour
one day when I first came across binary attributes
and I was just like, "It set to false, I know
it set to false." I'm looking at my markup;
I'm using the developer tools, until I realized
what a binary attribute actually meant. For
the required attribute on form elements, what
that's going to do is that's going to stop
the form from being submitted unless the user
has actually entered text in there. We've
also got some new CSS selectors that allow
us to provide much more visually intense stuff.
So, I can say, "Hey, input, when you've got
a focus," right? Or I could say, where, "input:required:invalid."
I want you to have a different set of styles
then when you have input, required and valid,
right? So, that's why you saw the checkmark
or the little red box. We've got an ability
to just with styling, right? In the past,
if we did this, we have to right some pretty
crazy JavaScript to do this. We had to use
somebody's library or it's just one of those
things where we didn't get the richness that
we can do with CSS 3. One of the other things
that we wanted to do was provide a really
fast experience, right? It's really important
that as people are using web applications
that they just are fast, right? They don't
want to be, "Oh, I clicked on this link and
then, you know, it's the Web of the 1990s
and I'm on the dial-up modem and, you know,
I'm waiting for my page." We want things to
be fast. Application cache allows us to cache
our entire application on the user's computer.
Now, you're probably sitting there going,
"Well, doesn't caching just do that in general?"
And yet, it mostly does. But, you've all--probably
only got a cache of maybe 50 or 100 megs or
maybe you've cranked it up and you've got
a fairly big cache. But think about all the
pages that you visit everyday and how quickly
that cache gets blown away, right? You've
just--you've looked at so much stuff that
you've clear that cache out, now, you go to
that application and it's got to re-download
everything. Well, that kind of sucks. With
App Cache, you can actually say, "Hey, I want
you to store all of the data about my application
on the--on the computer. The way you do that
isn't the HTML element; we need to add a manifest
file. That manifest file is a file that serve
from our server that says, "Hey, this is the
stuff that you should cache locally on the
user's computer." In the actually cache file,
its got a particular format, you got to say
cache manifest, you don't have to put a version
in there, I'd recommend it because the way
that the browser knows whether you're application
has been updated is by looking for changes
in that file, all right? So, you may change
one of your index.htm, all right? The browser
is not going to bother to go check to see
if index.htm has been updated because it's
cache locally. So, that's why you need to
change the version. It'll go up every time,
it'll try and get this app cache file and
do that one thing to do sort of call-out because
it's, again, one of those little things that
I thought with for about 20 minutes one day.
When your server serves the app cache file,
it need to be served with the mind type of
text cache-manifest, all right? So, you don't
need to set that into htaccess or however
you're doing that, you need to go do that.
There's also a bunch of JavaScript APIs that
allow you to go and really get program adit
with your App Cache. So that you can update
the application at specific times, maybe you
only want to update it when the user first
starts the application. Maybe you want to
ask the user before you update it because
you're making some major changes or a breaking
change or something like that. So, you've
got to set a JavaScript APIs that really allow
you to go through and be much more powerful
with App Cache. So, with that, I'm going to
pass it over to Ernest to talk about some
of the tools and resources.
>> DELGADO: Thanks, Pete. I'm going to go
really quick through this. And now that we've
seen APIs that we can use in our web app,
we may want to start coding and--but not doing
it from scratch. So, it's more mentioning
some tools here that will help us to do that.
The first one is Boilerplate. With Boilerplate,
you can go there and get the files that actually
would use--you would use as a template for
your app and it's at a different level. So,
there's like an index.html with the all the
header and the basic step that you need. So,
you needn't to worry about it. It also have--at
JavaScript level has like the includes that
if you want jQuery or the analytics snippet
in your--in your page, you have that there
as well. And it sees as level there are many
tweaks as well that you have--as like the
recent CSS, you have the template there or
for instance, Media Queries. Who in the audience
knows Media Queries? Not many. It's just like
a syntax to make your layout of the page change
depending on the device that is looking at
your page, so if it's a mobile browser, you
can say, "Okay, from this width to this other
width, change the layout to adapt to that
screen." Also, there's a list of what we call
Polyfills, because when you started calling
these APIs, you may not have the support in
all browsers that you want to support. And
I think it would be supported twice. But then,
this Polyfills are kind of a JavaScript scene
that it's looking for a work around. It's
actually taking care of that work around 100%.
So, the perfect Polyfill lets you write that
feature in modern syntax and it's going to--the
Polyfill's going to manage that to make that
feature work in the browser. So, it's possible
that not all the features have fallbacks for
all browsers, so that's one in your code;
you should maybe do the--like some fallback
case or a graceful degradation. But instead
of looking for the browser version, which
is not a very reliable technique, it's better
to do like feature detection. And for that,
you should use, or you can use Modernizr,
which has this necessary syntax that you can
put in your if statements and if that feature
is supported, do something, otherwise do the
fallback. If you want to take a look at the
growing support that all browsers are having
now with HTML5 features, go to this site,
it's really cool, it has all the tables and
version numbers and green if that feature
supported, caniuse.com. And another interesting
tool that we've been using for a long time,
maybe another browser is this kind of debugging
tool in the case of Chrome is called like
The Chrome Developer Tools. And tomorrow,
I think...
>> LEPAGE: Today--this...
>> DELGADO: Oh, today?
>> LEPAGE: Yes.
>> DELGADO: Okay. So, today, there's a talk
from [INDISTINCT] going through all the details
that the things you can do actually in this
debugger that there are things that I even
didn't know. And the cool stuff here is that,
it's also--it has the capabilities to debug
features like Web Workers or App Cache that
it was very difficult to debug if that wasn't
supported because Web Workers has a separate
JavaScript file. So, these debuggers actually
prepared for that. Some resources that we
are maintaining for with sample code, tutorials,
demos on html5rocks.com. A couple of books
that are quite interesting, Bruce Lawson and
Mark Pilgrim, and I think that's it with app
resources. So, I'm going to pass it over,
Pete to wrap up the presentation. So, all
can go wait.
>> LEPAGE: Awesome. So I'll just talk quickly
about Chrome Frame. If you've not played with
Chrome Frame before, super useful utility,
if you're stuck on older versions of IE for
any specific reason, Chrome Frame will allow
you to run HTML5 applications within Chrome
Frame. So, we've talked about some of the
great APIs and application level support that
HTML5 gives you. And we've also talked a lot
about some of the really cool rich user experience
stuff that we can really start building with
HTML5. I'm really excited to see what you
guys start building in terms of web applications.
This is really our opportunity to change the
Web from being a bunch of web pages and websites
to really being web applications that really
just change the way we think about the Web
and what we do on it. So, I encourage you
guys to go start playing with this stuff and
go using that. There's a couple of sessions
today. There's the Free Cake Session that
also goes into HTML5 development with the
Chrome Developer Tools, the two hour hands-on
lab. Really cool, as well as the Building
and Publishing Apps with the Chrome Web Store
at four. The rest of the week, whole bunch
of really awesome stuff. If you make it to
one session that is my favorite, the Showcase
for Web Devs, wow and a how really, really
cool session. I've seen some of the demos
these guys are doing, blow your pants off.
With that, I want to say thank you guys very
much. Please go fill out an evaluation form.
And thank you. We'll open it up to questions
now, but I know that some of you seemed to
be really hungry. So, feel free. But we'll
stick around and answer any questions you
want. Thank you.